take a look now at griffin canning the
starter
for the angels this evening canning lost
his first start of the year that was
monday in oakland he went four and two
thirds gave up three runs four hits
walked two
and struck out seven threw 82 pitches in
that ball game
as george springer will lead things off
for the astros good to see springer
break is over 14
yesterday as george had a couple of hits
and a couple of rbis
two on the way and springer to the left
side there is the vacuum known as
anthony rendon
and there's one away throat came off the
bag a little bit but
good job by matt dice to kind of stay
with it one down
if this ball hit pretty well and you see
random ranges
to his left makes a nice play there
takes his time
flips it over there matt theis making a
nice play coming
off the bag so now two outs and two men
on for
yuli guriel 3-2 did he go after that one
on the appeal the first base umpire says
yes struck him out
alonzo marquez the crew chief who made
that call on the appeal so canning
found a way to get out of trouble here
in the first inning they failed to score
ranking making his second start of the
season
sunday against the mariners got another
decision went three in the third gave
him three runs four hits walked two
and struck out two through just 58
pitches grenkey said after the game he
tired a little bit two out of no one on
for third baseman anthony rendon
breaking ball drops in for strike three
that was a beauty to rindon and the
enemy is over
one two three frame for grinky and after
one astros nothing
angels nothing here's springer springer
grounded out to begin the ball game
here's springer batting smacks one on an
easy hop right at rendon
who throws to first a little bit high
but slice gets the foot on the bag
and two quick outs out to va the next
batter
here's the pitch and it is strike three
called catching the inside corner a
little cutter in there
and ward goes down on strikes second
punch out for a grinky and there's two
outs
zach grenkey ate up eight down he is in
quite the groove early on here's guriel
really struck out his last time up
back up the middle it's going to be a
base hit for guriel so yulie guriel
hangs in there
and the astros with a couple of singles
in this frame and now two on and one
down
here's correa he grounded out as last
time up
here's the two one he's grounded to the
shortstop fletcher he's got it flipped
to second when he photo first
and it's a double play so that'll do it
the astros go down couple hits
they waste it and we'll go to the bottom
of the fourth inning in anaheim astros
nothing
angels nothing two outs now for rendon
rendon struck out looking his last time
up
granky gets a sign the deep breath the
the first pitch is a slider off the end
of the back grounded to the first
baseman guriel he's got it shovels it to
grinky covering the bag
and it's an easy inning three ground
outs one two three
and it's looking real nice for granky as
we go to the fifth inning it's no score
with the astros and angels so now the
astros is two on
so here's the 2-0 and he swings at this
one and pops it in a very shallow center
field going back on it and making a nice
catch is the second baseman rendezvous
goodwin was coming in
randhifa was going back and a good job
by luis
they never gave up on that one and makes
the catch if that ball drops in they
likely score a run grinky's been perfect
through the first five make that two
balls have left the infield
a couple of fly outs everything else a
ground out or a strikeout brinky has
struck out three
only needed 61 pitches to this point i
guess the astros have never had a
pitcher throw a perfect game in their
franchise history taylor ward ahead
in the count rips one he's got a base
hit
so finally the angels get a runner on
base there goes the perfect game there
goes the no hitter and taylor ward
spoils it all so now runners at the
corners and one out for david fletcher
who is over two
a fly out and a ground out two-two
coming
and fletcher gets one in the air to left
will this get home the run here comes
ward chugging on home and he will come
in and score
sacrifice fly from david fletcher and
the angels have the first run of the
night it's one nothing
gonna face one of the angels hottest
hitters in this young season
3-1 and goodwin rips one to right he's
got himself a basic
feis rounding third he's going to come
on in his score
throw down the second goodwin is there
two-nothing angels
on the rbi from brian goodwin well this
next guy could tie it up
george springer to the plate he's over
two in a walk
here's the 2-2 that balls off the fist
into shallow left field coming in on
upton and he'll have to play it on a hop
an rbi single for springer and it's 2-1
and rendon at the plate rendon's 0 for
three
and he's got a chance to give the angels
a little bit more room here
with two down in the eighth swings at
the first pitch
left side correa with the long throw and
not in time he pulls gloria off the bag
that means that ward will score and it's
3-1
angels robles with the 1-1
and reddick hits it in the air pretty
well out to right center field and you
can kiss that one goodbye
josh reddick's second hit of the game is
a home run
springer at the plate one for three with
an rbi single back in the seventh
now the two won the springer and
spranger drills this one deep to left
field and you can't kiss that one
goodbye
a go-ahead two-run home run for george
springer
and the astros go up four to three so
the angels have the tying run on and
they'll bring the winning run of the
play to jason castro
trying to be a hero for the angels in
the home ninth
castro hits one high in the air center
field and deep springer going back
it's off the top of the wall fred heapho
will come on in and score
castro with an rbi double the angels
have tied this game at four
and bases loaded one out and michael
hermacillo will get his chance to be a
hero
winning run on third hermesio gets into
one
right field will be deep enough
reddick's got a big r
zeiss coming home throws up the line the
angels win it